[Musica]
quanto sono state importanti per me e le
mie radici
moltissimo io sono nata a torino 58 anni
fa e durante l'estate i miei genitori mi
portavano in trascorrere le vacanze
estive in un paese di montagna nelle
valli di lanzo che si chiamava un segno
un piccolo paesino sperduto nelle
montane e tuttora frequentato da
pochissime persone
era bellissimo perché perché io essendo
nata a torino la libertà era una cosa
era difficile per un bambino invece un
segno eros e io rappresentava la libertà
assoluta potevo uscire di casa
potevo potevo andare in bicicletta e poi
e poi crescendo la nostra generazione
appunto sono del 1959
beh insomma i discorsi erano molti si
socializzava stando insieme e quindi poi
noi eravamo una generazione che voleva
cambiare il mondo
avevamo la presunzione di voler cambiare
il mondo e che cosa facevamo in questo
paesino ci trovavamo soprattutto in un
bosco in un posto particolare in un
bosco dove c'erano questi alberi immensi
io ricordo queste radici che di anno in
anno erano sprofondavano sempre di più e
questi alberi diventavano sempre più
grandi con queste fronde che andavano a
cercare verso l'alto la luce allora di
cosa ricordo della mia infanzia
questo questo tempo il tempo dedicato
agli amici agli amici veri quelli che
poi rimangono per sempre
il resto sono conoscenti ma invece c'è
quella parte di noi quella parte che ci
appartiene
le radici quelli sono gli amici veri
quelli che poi ci aiuteranno tutta la
vita nel percorso ci saranno sempre ma
poi c'era un'altra cosa che io ricordo
di quell'infanzia ed era il colore del
cielo
azzurro beh insomma la mia vita mi ha
portato a viaggiare molto soprattutto
per lavoro
quindi ho visto albe dappertutto in
molte parti del mondo ma l'azzurro che
io vedevo un segno l'ho visto solo lì è
perché certo prima c'era la colazione e
la mia mamma mi preparava all'epoca si
mangia vallate colpa né colpa né di
montagna con l'acqua buona fatto col
forno a legna erano cose semplici molto
semplici mio padre era un sopravvissuto
a un campo di concentramento quindi
c'era un'attenzione al dettaglio la
piccole cose quanto tutto questo mi è
servito poi per creare per per per avere
le esperienze che poi mi hanno mi hanno
condotto a diventare la persona che sono
io da bambina volevo fare la maestra
su questo non c'era dubbio è un certo
punto della mia vita l'ho pure fatto e
credo tuttora che alcune volte mi
ritrovo a farlo o ad avere la sensazione
di farlo anche in fabbrica ma non solo
in fabbrica anche nel nella fondazione
dei musei di venezia dove ho l'onore di
essere di prestare servizio e e allora
perché maestra ma perché c'è questa
voglia di di insegnare e e di stare a
contatto con quei bambini col futuro
allora le radici e il nostro futuro e ma
le radici al futuro bel titolo
estremamente impegnativo perché noi
siamo siamo il frutto delle nostre
esperienze
allora io sono una maratoneta corro da
sempre surfista per scelte maratoneta
per scelta il surfista per necessità
perché nel 1998 i miei figli mi ha detto
noi vogliamo fare solo figlio se i figli
e quindi io andavo a fare surf o loro
non avrebbero mai fatto ma tutta questa
questa esperienza
che anno dopo anno hanno creato il
tronco anno hanno costruito il tronco
della mia persona quanto è stata
importante quanto è stato importante lo
sport
l'adattabilità la resilienza che ho
imparato giorno dopo giorno a a
costruire dentro di me se mi chiedete
qual è la più bella maratona che io ho
fatto non vi racconto certamente quella
che ci ho messo minor tempo ma la più
faticosa quella più difficile quella
dove una sciatalgia mia mia purtroppo
quasi fermato e sono arrivate alla fine
trascinando la gamba ma volevo arrivare
all'obiettivo dovevo arrivare
all'obiettivo
non potevo fermarmi ma nella stessa con
la stessa logica la capacità di
adattamento la capacità di poter
comprendere come possiamo riscrivere la
storia perché vedete io a 58 anni
il futuro forse lo posso lo posso
immaginare i giovani lo vedono allora le
nostre tradizioni e io parlo io
rappresento un'azienda che ha mille a
250 anni che è del 1770 e quindi come
poter pensare di traghettare questa
questa fabbrica verso il futuro
semplicissimo creando all'interno della
fabbrica un museo un museo che potesse
in qualche modo raccontare le nostre
origini
perché la fabbrica non può stare senza
la cultura e la fuga e la cultura non
può stare senza la fabbrica
guardate guardate dove siamo no che
dimora che dimora maestosa pensate
riscrivere il futuro anche dei musei e
come immaginandoli dei salotti veneziani
aperti dove per esempio poter poter
poterci lavorare e infatti abbiamo
creato degli spazi di coworking quindi
vedere le stesse cose ma con
un'angolazione diversa portare tutto
quello che è la nostra esperienza
all'interno delle nostre attività
lavorative o personali ma cos'è il
futuro beh la grande rivoluzione di
assumere le donne non può esistere un
futuro se noi non assumiamo le donne se
non portiamo nelle aziende e nei gruppi
di lavoro le donne le donne perché
bisogna creare dei team dei team misti
dei t e bisogna creare dei gruppi di
lavoro dove le donne che non sono
migliori della juvi degli uomini ma sono
solo diverse possano dire possano dire
quello che pensano
vedete è la strada è lunga perché quando
si parla quando si parla di futuro
possiamo possiamo possiamo immaginare
qualsiasi cosa ma io sono convinta che
il futuro il futuro è oggi è quello che
noi stiamo facendo oggi è il nostro
impegno quotidiano per il per un futuro
migliore per i nostri figli e per quanto
mi riguarda per i nostri nipoti perché
non possiamo pensare di essere
scollegati da una realtà di essere
scollegati da una realtà che ci sta
chiedendo sempre sempre di più di essere
sostenibili di avere l'opportunità di di
poter esserci e fare ogni giorno la
nostra parte perché non è che lo debbano
solo fare gli imprenditori non è che lo
debbano solo fare gli operai tutti siamo
chiamati a farlo vedete se stavo proprio
pensando a pinocchio perché pinocchio
beh perché era una canzone che i miei
genitori mi cantavano sempre da piccoli
carissimo pinocchio e quindi per me è
sempre stato un mantra la figura di
pinocchio figura fortissima perché
immaginate mastro geppetto era stanco
era stufo della sua vita è un certo
punto vede questo tronco per lui non era
un tronco
per tutti gli altri era un pezzo di
legno da buttare via
per lui non era un tronco aveva visto un
bambino aveva visto il futuro è certo
gli è costato molto fatica perché
pinocchio l'ha fatto impazzire ma tutti
noi siamo pinocchio per il semplice
motivo che tutti noi nella nostra vita
abbiamo trovato un grillo parlante un
gatto che ci ha tradito e magari anche
una fata turchina
perché vedete mastro mastro geppetto nel
riuscire a comprendere la forza di in
quel pezzo di legno ha fatto una
grandissima rivoluzione è quello che è
importante è che se tutti noi siamo
stati pinocchio e parlo di quelli della
mia generazione
adesso dobbiamo restituire e dobbiamo
diventare tutti del mastro geppetto e
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di
avvicinarsi ai giovani farli entrare nei
nostri gruppi di lavoro che siano
aziende che siano fondazioni ed avere il
coraggio di aprire le porte perché se
vogliamo fare un cambiamento e lo
dobbiamo fare perché io voglio io ci
voglio essere in questa parte
meravigliosa
in questo momento storico perché noi in
questo momento siamo esattamente in un
meraviglioso rinascimento italiano
la dobbiamo riscrivere questa storia ma
la dobbiamo riscrivere tutti insieme
e allora io non ho paura dei giovani ai
giovani non devono avere paura delle
persone quei capelli bianchi come me
perché solo insieme possiamo parlare di
futuro radici al futuro
grazie
[Applauso]